all they need is a 330 meter tall tower  with 82 floors  2041 stairs and 900 runners from across  the globe who are willing to race to the  top of Beijing's tallest tower yeah it's  really healthy exercise because it is so  intense it's not something that is very  time consuming so you can do an amazing  workout in 15 minutes half an hour and  it's great aerobic most of us would be  happy doing our amazing workout at the  local park or at least somewhere closer  to home arriving for the races they are  far away from home just one day before  the race and after today's I'm going  back so no jet like I don't have time to  get used to other things on this event  is part of a series of vertical races  across the globe  so Beijing's winners will be seeing each  other again soon at their next amazing  workout